bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au sommaire de ça vous regarde ce soir
l'union sacrée contre le corps la virus
dès lundi tous les établissements
scolaires seront fermés mais les
élections municipales
elles auront bien lieu ce dimanche alors
ces mesures prises sont elles cohérente
et surtout à la hauteur peut-on rassurer
sans bloquer le pays
c'est notre grand débat ce soir le
gouvernement interdit aussi les
rassemblements de plus de 100 personnes
ce qui signifie que toutes les salles de
spectacles vont devoir fermer c'est une
annonce dès voir philippe à la mi
journée c'est un coup de massue pour le
monde de la culture on en parlera et
puis on reviendra aussi sur des accents
socialiste des manuels et maquereau qui
ont surpris hier le chef de l'état
promet des décisions de rupture après la
crise alors que comprendre et ont un
tournant du quinquennat un virage à
gauche un virage sur l'europe ou sur le
capitalisme on en parle dans un instant
avec nos invités tous ces sujets on les
aborde aussi avec notre grand témoin ce
soir c'est natacha polony
la patronne de l'hebdomadaire marianne
voilà c'est par qui vous savez tout on y
va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir natacha
polony bonsoir et merci d'être notre
grand témoin vous diriger la rédaction
de marianne on va revenir sur ce
discours d' emmanuel macron sur les
mesures
le changement de ton aussi sur la forme
peut-être sur le fond vous nous direz
vous diallo gré ce soit avec aurélien
tâche et bonsoir vous êtes député la
république en marche du val d'oise ainsi
que mathieu plane de l'ofce
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques
on va revenir sur les mesures mais celui
qui ouvre le bal vous le connaissez
désormais c'est stéphane figurez vous
qu'on a retrouvée l'union sacrée
stéphane blakowski et si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite et à tous ses fans
si j'ai bien compris ce soir bah si j'ai
bien compris mais rien désolé j'ai parlé
un petit peu trop vite hier mais c'est
dire que toute la journée on avait
entendu les leaders de l'opposition qui
critiquaient le gouvernement dont la
droite disait mais ils n'en font pas
assez pour les entreprises la gauche 10
et n'en font pas assez pour les
précaires bon on avait le sentiment qu'à
13 politiques étaient rompues et le soir
quand le président dirait chers
compatriotes je vous appelle à l'unité
nationale et ben il serait pas du tout
entendu et vous êtes troupe est donc et
je ne sais pas complètement trompé mais
je suis assez complètement content de
m'être le trip et finalement vous
rappelle qu' on s'inquiétait un peu
quand même à l'idée qu'ils auraient le
report des municipales que forcément
l'un
l'opposition allait s'indigner bien
compte cette fameuse unité nationale
elle est explosée bref le scénario du
pire mais bon ça natacha lecerf les
journalistes ont ce petit péché c'est
que sont toujours fascinés par le
scénario du pire de ce que vient en plus
ça se passe mal plus est de choses à
raconter mais l'unité nationale tient le
coup mais l'unité pour l'instant on
tient le coup évidemment puisque ce
matin les républicains et les
socialistes ont le sentiment enfin que
d'être plutôt apaisé par les annonces
d'hier du président donc ils ont réagi
par tweet je vous fais d'envoi ekwalla
damien bat donc il est président du
groupe à l'assemblée a trouvé que le
président était à la hauteur et de son
côté olivier faure lui aussi a dit qu'il
avait le sentiment d'être entendu donc
il ya même une volonté dans la majorité
de la classe politique de ne pas
polémiquer
même jean luc mélenchon qui n'est pas le
dernier à appeler à l'insurrection
régulièrement eh bien il a dit non c'est
pas le moment de critiquer le
gouvernement moment n'est pas celui de
la polémique c'est le moment de la
solidarité de la cohésion et du devoir
personnel individuel de respecter les
consignes et de se porter au secours de
ceux qui sont les plus dans le besoin de
l'entr'aide donc finalement le seul ce
qu'ils refusent d'unité nationale c'est
le rassemblement national
oui cela dit marine le pen a annoncé
qu'elle était déjà candidate pendant les
22 donc elle est déjà un peu en campagne
parce qu emmanuel macron à ça dans un
coin de la tête aussi donc d'ailleurs ne
son discours rien c'est quand même il ya
quand même dit que l'un des principaux
écueils pour lutter contre l' l'épidémie
c'était le repli nationaliste donc
forcément marine le pen s'est senti visé
il manque ne pas se sentir visés puisque
depuis le début elle réclame des
contrôles plus stricts aux frontières
donc après le discours du président elle
a enfoncé le clou en drapant pour elle
il fallait fermer les frontières en
écoute on se retrouve dans une situation
où les français ne peuvent pas aller en
italie puisque l'italie s'est elle même
auto confiné mais où les italiens
peuvent très librement venir en france
ça n'a pas de sens objectivement ça n'a
pas de sens sympa de sens de laisser la
frontière et j'en arrivais par exemple
de pays comme l'iran qui sont
terriblement touchés par l'épidémie un
des premiers moyens de freiner
l'épidémie était évidemment d'effectuer
un contrôle aux frontières alors
pourquoi la france n'a eu depuis le
départ le gouvernement dit nous ont fait
confiance aux scientifiques donc pour
l'instant le conseil scientifique
estimé qu' à plus davantage ne pas
fermer les frontières que de juste jouer
davantage de ne pas les fermer que de la
fermer donc le gouvernement s'il tient
mais président a dit hier attention
peut-être qu'on les ferme n'aura plus
tard mais on demandera alors on ne fera
pas ça tout seul dans notre coin donc
déjà il ya un truc qui décale qui
déraille l'événement les allemands
voient eux ont craqué ils ont réinstallé
des contrôles à la frontière puis ils
sont pas les seuls à pas trop avoir
envie d'en recevoir deux français jules
à se jeter un oeil sur la carte canon
que c'est une vingtaine de pays qu'on
soit carrément interdit accueille des
français donc ça c'est en rouge comme
les etats-unis ou qui pose des mesures
de quarantaine
donc on voit qu'en france marine le pen
est plutôt isolé sur cette question de
fermeture des frontières mais canada à
l'international comme c'est une solution
qui commence à avoir pas mal de
partisans donc j'imagine que si à terme
on doit fermer les frontières sera
plutôt un événement qui servira à marine
le pen qui serait plutôt à son avantage
mais comme je voulais dit je peux me
tromper
merci stéphane le maroc aussi un qui
ferme ses portes à nos ressortissants et
et à la france
aurélien taché par partons du du billet
de stéphane c'est cohérent
c'est cohérent ces mesures franchement
si on prend la question des frontières
un emmanuel macron qui vise très
clairement marine le pen en disant pas
de repli nationaliste mais finalement
les fermera peut-être pas maintenant
peut-être pas celle qu'on croit
peut-être pas celle du pays mais
peut-être celle de l'europe ou alors
localement par région c'est c'est
audible et compréhensible par les gens
ça c'est typiquement le piège dans
lequel il ne faut pas tomber
l'espèce de facilité qui consisterait à
dire on va fermer la frontière et ça va
tout régler
on voit que c'est ce que donald trump
lui a fait parce que comme il n'est
absolument pas préparés à gérer la crise
du coronavirus il a eu un réflexe assez
simple c'est de dire c'est la faute de
l'europe qui sait pas gérer cela vaut
dès chinois répit nous on ferme tout et
on est et on transfère entre vicat en
russie qui a fermé ses frontières 34e et
d'en garder un petit peu la carte que
vous avez montré on ferme ou là où les
nationalistes ont gagné sept roms ces
maudits c'est boutines c'est ce qui
effectivement prône cela donc il ya une
approche et des williams car populiste
de là je crois que ce qui est beaucoup
plus important et qui moi m'a inquiété
ces derniers jours et je suis rassuré
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut que
l'europe
elles réagissent
ce n'est pas normal qu'on n'est attendue
finalement que les chinois proposent aux
italiens de les aider pour avoir une
réaction forte
cette réaction forte est arrivé
aujourd'hui la présidente de la
commission européenne a annoncé qu'il y
aurait donc un fonds avec 37 milliards
d'euros qui serait mis en place pour
cible et effectivement les dégâts du
coup ravi rude sur le plan sanitaire ou
économique
donc nous on est cohérent on réclame une
intervention forte de l'europe parce
qu'on croit que c'est en coordonnant nos
réponses et nos efforts qu'on viendra à
bout d'un d'un finalement d'un normale
qui est transnational et donc on va
effectivement si on aurait fermé les
frontières le faire encore dit non quand
son corps de ballet et qu'en allemagne
le fait son côté en pétard et la
naissance tant fait l'allemagne
l'allemagne n'aurait pas dû agir
unilatéralement allemagne a freiné pour
le pour le plan de relance de l'europe
l'allemagne n'est pas forcément à la
hauteur en ce moment non voilà mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut que nous on
soit mauvais élève aussi au contraire on
impulse autre chose et on a des
résultats la preuve avec la tâche a dit
que vous allez réussir je voudrais qu'on
écoute juste le président la république
pour rien qu'on comprenne les les mots
employés est ce qu'il fait de la
politique
ou est ce qu'il annonce des mesures à
venir écouter nous devons aujourd'hui
éviter deux écueils mes chers
compatriotes
d'une part le repli nationaliste ce
virus il n'a pas de passeport
nous aurons sans doute des mesures de
contrôle des fermetures de frontière à
prendre mais il faudra les prendre quand
elles seront pertinentes et il faudra
les prendre en européen à l'échelle
européenne
natacha polony ça peut passer ça ce
discours là un préalable
je trouve qu emmanuel macron a été tout
à fait à la hauteur hier qu'il a été
très bon que sur les mesures sanitaires
il me semble que y'a pas grand chose à
redire
je pense que il est nécessaire de temps
en temps de reconnaître en effet que je
vois pas qui aurait pu faire tellement
mieux
en revanche après il faut être précis
quand j'entends aurélien tâche et dire
que ce sont les populistes qui ferment
leurs frontières c'est factuellement
faux il ya des pays qui sont absolument
pas populiste qui ont fermé leurs
frontières ça veut pas dire que je pense
qu'il faut les fermer
mais là ce qui me
me semble assez intéressant c'est que
évidemment on n'a pas besoin il est
fermé tous nos voisins les ont fermé
pour nous donc on peut continuer à dire
nous on est généreux il ne faut surtout
pas se replier de toutes façons de fait
ça ne circulent plus alors le principe
c'est de se demander exactement comment
l'europe aurait pu réagir parce que je
vous entends et le président de la
république a raison de dire que dans un
monde idéal oui ça devrait être une
réponse européenne
mais de fait ça n'en est pas une europe
est totalement morte c'est à dire qu'on
voit bien que au pied du mur face à une
crise comme celle ci il n'y a pas la
moindre solidarité et c'est bien ça qui
est préoccupant alors on peut
reconnaître à humaines malades macron
d'avoir essayé depuis quelques mois de
proposer des choses pour construire une
europe
il s'est heurté à un mur et là au moment
où il faudrait une véritable solidarité
on s'aperçoit qu'elle n'existe pas c'est
pour ça que je ce que je regrette dans
votre discours c'est cette ce côté
comment dire ce faux lyrisme il ya un
moment où il faut reconnaître
honnêtement les choses mais bon en effet
la nuit leur réserve la décision qui a
été prise aujourd'hui même polony vous
avez bien vu que justement un plan
venait d'être débloqué après leur zéro
europe est quelque chose qui vous a pas
échappé j'en suis certain en tout cas
moi c'est le cas en mettant les traités
de côté les fameux traité qui impose le
libre échange et qui peuvent être
parfois critiquée je crois que vous le
faites vous même et où je peux avoir des
choses à redire aussi là dessus et là on
dit que les aides aux entreprises par
exemple qui sont interdites par les
traités européens et bien on va
suspendre cela on va mettre 37 milliards
d'euros
on aurait eu cette conversation hier
j'aurais été obligé d'aborder dans votre
sens
mais aujourd'hui la décision était prise
de débloquer ces 31 milliard d'euros
donc on va se tourner vers l'économie
dieu vous êtes mathieu plane 37
milliards d'euros au niveau de l'union
européenne je donne quelques chiffres
pour comprendre un petit peu parce qu'on
pense à la crise de 2008 et on se
rappelle que comme ça il y avait des
plans de relance massifs partout pas
titre de comparaison l'allemagne à des
blocs débloquer le plus grand plan daide
de son histoire par la forme de prêts de
100 limit 550 milliards d'euros l'europe
pour la 10 37 la chine 70 milliards
d'euros les états unis 1500 milliards
d'euros injectés via la fed la réserve
fédérale américaine et la france oui
mais alors attention il ya des choux et
des carottes
ça donne le tournis c'est pas une
dépense budgétaire équivalente à faire
une mesure de chômage partiel par
exemple un que vous allez pas récupérer
donc confronte ce que met la banque
centrale sur la table par rapport à la
question budgétaire de ce que les états
vont engager ça absolument rien à voir
pour l'instant on n'a pas chômé 500
milliards c'est pas on peut pas le
comparer comme ça c'est pas une critique
voilà et c'est pareil sur les décalages
de trésorerie c'est une mesure
nécessaire c'est à dire que s'ils
voulaient éviter que c'est un nombre de
boîtes mettent pas la clef enfin vous
éviter qu'elles mettent la clé sous la
porte
seuls moyens quand elles n'ont pas
d'activité c'est de faciliter la
trésorerie et donc l'action budgétaire
des pouvoirs publics qui est une des
bonnes réactions c'est de dire on décale
le paiement d'un certain nombre d'impôts
tva cotisations sociales qu'elle ne les
paierons pas un jour c'est à vous de
décaler juste le paiement des contrées
que c'est un repas fait un report mais
pas une adepte voilà une annulation qui
étaient prévues dans des sapeurs ça peut
faire si vous faites le calcul ça peut
faire vite 30 40 milliards sur un mois
donc céder ses conséquences ça veut pas
dire que cet argent est totalement
injecté c'est pareil pour une banque
centrale quant à va prêter de l'argent
aux banques
le prête avec des conditions qui sont
favorables mais cet argent sera
remboursé donc ça c'est déjà une des
premières distinctions après la réponse
ce pays pays par pays parce que d'abord
on n'a pas les mêmes systèmes de santé
on voit bien on voit que on n'a pas géré
la crise sanitaire de la même façon et à
certains pays qui ont rapidement mis en
place du confinement
d'autres ont mis effectivement ont fermé
un certain nombre d'écoles non là on a
choisi aussi une stratégie qui a été un
peu différent donc c'est vrai que la
question européenne elle paraît presque
décalé là dessus c'est à dire que mais
vous faites partie parce qu'ils ont
trouvé qu'il y avait un retard à
l'allumage et l'europe
je veux dire un budget de 1 % du pib
qu'est ce qu'elle peut vraiment faire à
part dire effectivement on sort des 3 %
mais on va pas dire on va respecter les
critères budgétaires aujourd'hui la
question elle va se poser là on est dans
les mesures de soutien mesures d'urgence
je pense que ces pays par pays où il
faut des mesures rapides opérationnel et
ça c'est au niveau national que vous
allez prendre dans une sortie de crise
c'est à dire peut-être dans quatre-cinq
mois il va falloir coordonnées
effectivement des plans de relance
intéressant intelligent pas dépenser
d'argent non importe comment il savoir
comment on fait repartir les économies
et la coordination sera importante là
dans l'urgence le traitement d'urgence
il se fait surtout pays par pays après
ce que peut dire l'europe c'est
effectivement aujourd'hui on va pas
regarder les 3% effectivement on va pas
regarder les aides sectorielles parce
que d'habitude c'est considérer comme
des distorsions de concurrence
mais ça c'est le minimum on va dire on
vous quoi qu'il en coûte ça a été
répétée trois fois par le président de
la république
aujourd'hui on entend bruno le maire
répété qu on fera le nécessaire et même
plus ce qu'est ce que ça signifie
finalement ça veut dire que l'état ouvre
la dépense publique pour soutenir et
même au delà
les conséquences économiques
principalement oui d'abord sur la partie
crise conjoncturelle et puis après et
même une ouverture qui a été fait de
plus importante que sa part le président
de république mais qui sur déjà les 3%
et maintenant peut-être qu'on va arriver
effectivement au moment où on va falloir
poser un certain nombre de questions
mais en attendant déjà dans l'urgence
hurle au niveau national la mesure de
prise en compte du chômage partiel à
100% par l'état c'est quelque chose de
très fort la question qui va se poser
aussi c'est de savoir si cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage la s'appliquer ou
non je souhaiterais qu'on puisse aussi
étendre le chômage partiel à d'autres
travailleurs précarisés type
travailleurs indépendants vtc et autres
on voit bien qu'on est en train sur le
plan social effectivement de mettre les
moyens pour que la crise ne touche pas
les plus vulnérables pour qu'elle ne
touche pas les plus fragiles ce sera
aussi le cas pour nous nos aînés je
pense et des décisions fortes devront
être prises aussi dans ce domaine là et
puis bien sûr il ya la partie de soutien
aux entreprises donc pour répondre à
votre question très claire n'a été vu
chez gestion de la dépense publique et
de la lutte contre les déficits ne
viendra pas grives et tout ce qui doit
être fait pour protéger les français ont
d'ores et déjà les 3 % on oublie web en
donne c'est une question que je connais
bien sûr qu'ils ont va être très loin
fayyad alors qu'un double choc non mais
quand vous avez un choc comme ça
macroéconomique votre activité chuter
des recettes fiscales en moins à ce
qu'il
- bénéfice donc moins d'impôts c'était
il ya moins de consommation il ya moins
de tva ça c'est le choc naturel c'est
conjoncturel et ça ça peut vous déjà
faire représenter des dizaines de
milliards d'euros et à sa va s'ajouter
les mesures de soutien et de relance
donc bien sûr qu'on va être de l'adav
d'ailleurs la question qui va se poser
en sortie de crise et à quelle vitesse
on va essayer de résorber ses déficits
et pas faire les mêmes erreurs qui ont
été faites en 2009 quand on a voulu
réduire trop vite et déficit qu'on arcas
et casser la reprise mais là je pense
qu'on n'en est pas là aujourd'hui mais
en tout cas il faut bien sûr pour éviter
que cette crise et des conséquences
durables et structurelle il faut
absorber le choc et absorber le choc ça
veut dire que les ports publics l'état
fait fait ce qu'il peut pour l'ensemble
de la population terre comporte et aux
parents qui vont devoir prendre des
nounous donc ça il faut des indemnités
aux salariés aux entreprises aux
indépendants il ya deux ans du village
il ya deux cibles agit à la fois sur les
entreprises à travers le préserver le
tissu productif et pour les ménages et
les salariés c'est préserver en gros
leur pouvoir d'achat et pour l'emploi se
pose la question des contrats courts les
temporaires les intérimaires et les cdd
eux qui risquent d'avoir certains
endroits même parce qu'ils bénéficient
pas du chômage partiel
vous portez quel regard au fond sur
cette façon finalement que le monde à
ouvrir les vannes de la dépense pour
sauver je vois là chacun des états on a
l'impression qu'on revient un petit peu
2008 est ce que c'est comparable ou
c'est assez différente dans la mesure où
la crise ne vient pas de la finance
cette fois ci et elle va venir de
l'économie réelle au départ et il va y
avoir des situations absolument tragique
parce que vous avez déjà des gens je
pense par exemple un exemple un
photographe dans l'événementiel
d'entreprise ya plus d'événementiel il
est en indépendance afin de bosser avec
lui c'est un exemple réel qui disent ils
n'ont plus rien pas de revenus et ça
fait partie de ces gens qui vont qui
sont totalement précaire là le constat
qu'on peut faire c'est que le système
qui consiste à précariser le travail est
absolument calamiteux alors on peut se
réjouir que les politiques s'en rendent
compte aujourd'hui mais ça aurait été
mieux de s'en rendre compte
avant c'est bien ça le problème c'est à
dire que là on s'aperçoit quand on
écoute le président de la république on
s'aperçoit qu'il nous dit voilà on ne
peut pas continuer comme ça il va y
avoir une rupture
là on parle de restaurer la souveraineté
alimentaire
donc nous devons produire chez nous mais
pourquoi dans ces cas-là avoir expliqué
pendant vingt ans que les gens qui
disaient cela était des nationalistes
étaient des populistes et c'était
absolument aberrant on s'aperçoit en
effet qu'un système qui précarisent les
salariés en les incitant à aller vers
l'auto entreprenariat et ben ça provoque
en cas de choc de ce style de ce style
là des situations tragiques que quand on
décide pour des raisons de coût de
fabriquer ailleurs et bien on dépend
totalement des autres pays c'est tout ça
qui est en train de se jouer en direct
la question c'est est ce qu'on va
réussir à réparer ça suffisamment vite
pour que les dégâts ce ne soit pas trop
de réparer et peut-être changé après la
crise on va maintenant parler de ce
nouveau modèle de développement keller
de souhaiter le président de la
république entend tous les cas il a
interrogé notre modèle actuel c'était à
la fin de son discours alors de quoi at
il parlé précisément on voit cela avec
clément pernot ce que révèle d'ores et
déjà cette pandémie
c'est que la santé gratuite sans
conditions de revenus de parcours ou de
profession notre état providence ne sont
pas des coûts ou des charges mais des
biens précieux des atouts indispensables
quand le destin frappe
emmanuel macron en défenseur de l'état
providence
ce passage de son allocution a surpris
notamment à gauche mesdames et messieurs
il aura fallu une crise il est vrai
mondiale pour que le président de la
république comprenne qu'un monde est un
modèle de monde est mort s'il ne va pas
aussi loin le président de la république
estime qu'il y aura effectivement un
avant et un après coronavirus en matière
de politique économique
il nous faudra demain tirer les leçons
du moment que nous traversons interrogé
le modèle de développement dans lequel
s'est engagé notre monde depuis des
décennies et qui dévoile ces failles au
grand jour les prochaines semaines et
les prochains mois
nécessiteront des décisions de rupture
en ce sens je les assume cette crise
sanitaire sonne-t-elle le glas de la
rigueur budgétaire et de la
mondialisation à tout crin pour les
économistes libéraux il ne faut pas
tirer de conclusions trop hâtives
il ya des constantes c'est pas parce que
tout à coup on redécouvre que le système
public de santé est une chose
souhaitable que il ne faudra pas un état
efficace
on a un niveau de dépense publique qui
est très supérieur à celui des autres
pays
si la crise est courte on l'aura on
l'aura oublié pour l'essentiel avant
noël on s'en souviendra
sur le plan sanitaire mais ça sera plus
qu'un mauvais souvenir qu'ils marquent
ou non un tournant dans le quinquennat
ses propos du président sont des signaux
clairs allèles gauche de sa majorité qui
semble douter ces dernières semaines des
signaux aussi au personnel soignant en
colère qui portent en eux la réussite ou
non de la gestion de crise je voyais
vous voyez faire une moue un peu
dubitative
natacha polony est ce que ce qu'on
entend dans la bouche du président a
selon vous c'est un changement de ton ou
fait un changement de cap de la forme
j'ai fait j'espère que c'est du fond
j'espère que c'est un véritable
changement de cap parce que de toute
façon c'est totalement
sr il est vrai hélas qu emmanuel macron
nous a habitués depuis le début a
d'excellents discours parce qu'en
général les discours on peut applaudir
du début à la fin
enfin pas à chaque fois mais souvent
très bon discours est derrière en
général il n'y a rien et là c'est vrai
que c'est un tel changement réside au
soir nous a parlé du pognon de dengue
est celui qui maintenant fait l'éloge du
de l'état providence
celui qui trouvait que les traités de
libre-échange c'était formidable vient
nous expliquer qu'il faut assurer la
souveraineté alimentaire donc qui vaut
mieux éviter de ruiner nos agriculteurs
et les services publics aussi bien sûr
en dehors de nos logiques de marché at
il expliqué la question c'est celle de
la cohérence
alors peut-être at-il tout à coup la
vierge peut être l'a compris je me
plaisait mais j'adorerais et dans ces
cas-là j'applaudirais voilà dans ces
cas-là si vraiment ce discours-là trouve
des mesures concrètes qui viendront le
conte fait le conforter gs je serai la
première à applaudir
mais ce serait pas mal de reconnaître
quand on s'est planté grave il a vu la
vierge ou pas c'est pareil on a contient
mais non en tout cas ce que je peux dire
effectivement moi je vous entends sur
notamment les sujets de soins
alimentaires et d'autres vous fais
partie de ceux qui portent ces sujets
depuis longtemps après attention les
ventes de type de réponse aujourd'hui on
n'est pas à la hauteur
est ce que ça veut dire pour autant
qu'il faut avoir une réponse qui serait
une mise en retrait par rapport à
l'union européenne par exemple faire ça
très bien tant mieux personne tant mieux
tant mieux mais moi je crois plutôt que
c'est ans et de plus d'europe qu'on aura
besoin tout à l'heure vous disiez sortir
des 3% et mettre cette règle de côté
pour faire face à la crise au plan de
relance
moi j'espère qu'on va tirer le fil un
peu plus loin et qu'on va se demander si
par exemple les dépenses de santé les
dépenses liées à la protection des plus
vulnérables
on voit bien que nous sommes face à des
crises sanitaires écologique de
migration aussi quand il dit pardonnez
moi de vous interromps il aura fallu
cette crise mondiale pour que le
président de la république comprenne que
le modèle d'un monde est mort mais il a
raison par mick parce que si emmanuel
macron ne va pas dire demain que
finalement la france doit se couper du
reste du monde comme le fait donald
trump comme le font les gens contre qui
ils opposent des thèses adverse depuis
longtemps sur le multilatéralisme sur la
coopération internationale par contre
redonner de la du comment de la crise ça
sera dur parce que je en train de dire
si vous saurez si vous permettez à
l'union européenne de d'avoir une action
un peu différente de celle que les
traités lui il laisse à voir aujourd'hui
sur la capacité de soutenir les
entreprises sur la capacité de ne plus
comptabiliser dans les 3% de déficit un
certain nombre de dépenses de santé
liées au climat et à la protection des
plus vulnérables
vous avez des moyens d'action politique
absolument déterminant la même c'est que
vous nous sortez ça comme un mantra
d'ailleurs il faut plus d'europe depuis
que vous êtes en politique vous nous
expliquer qu'il faut plus d'europe
quelle europe avec quels moyens avec
quels partenaires
c'est ça la question ça ne veut rien
dire plus d'europe d'ailleurs ce qui est
très intéressant dans le discours d'
emmanuel macron c'est que lui qui depuis
le début de son mandat nous parle de
souveraineté européenne sans définir
jamais ce que ça signifie exactement
pour moi je suis pas contre en effet il
faut définir des indes et ce sur quoi
nous devons être indépendants ce sur
quoi l'europe doit être indépendante
mais souveraineté européenne
il faut dire ce que ça signifie or là il
est allé un peu plus loin pour la
première fois il a parlé de souveraineté
française et européenne on sent léger
glissement pourquoi parce qu'il a très
bien compris justement que la l'europe
vient de montrer qu'elles étaient
incapables de réagir ou qu'elle mettait
un temps infini à temps derrière le
problème à la question c'est comment il
va faire pour imposer les solutions face
à une allemagne qui a décidé de jouer
perso
de toute façon comme à chaque fois que
plane comme j'aimerais votre analyse la
sueur sur cette femme discours qu
avez-vous compris il est pas il n'est
pas très 9,1 ce débat fait non les
économistes les intellectuels même les
politiques long mais la section c'est
vrai que l'on peut penser qu'il ya un
avant et un après coronavirus
et donc on va voir jusqu'où l'europe est
capable d'évoluer là dessus y compris
dans la crise parce qu'on va voir le
rôle de la banque centrale aussi
inquiets crime déterminant on l'a vu et
christine lagarde hier en fait on parle
d'une crise sanitaire qui a une crise
économique a des répercussions
financières
aujourd'hui l'italie est extrêmement
exposées le risque c'est que l'italie se
retrouve sous la soul attaques des
marchés financiers et notamment sur sa
d'être en concédant que c'est ça devient
plus soutenable si l'italie peu plus en
train de dire quoi concrètement
concrètement quels pourraient être mises
en défaut c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on voit danser exigent des taux de
rendement plus en plus élevés sur
l'italie alors qu'ils demandent des taux
de rendement plus en plus bas pour
l'allemagne pour la france
la crise des dettes souveraines comme on
la reconnaît très exactement le risque
de ça c'est que au bout de deux trois
mois s'aperçoivent que l'italie soit en
grande difficulté et qui venait pas
d'autre recours que l'accès au marché et
donc à ce moment là c'est qu'est ce que
fait la banque centrale et la banque
centrale c'est vrai que mario draghi
l'avait sauvé l'europe en domino avec le
wat tv hi tech c'est à dire qu'il a tout
fait pour garantir l'euro et le fait que
la zone euro n'éclatera pas ce qui veut
dire que la valeur d'un euro italien il
a même qu'un euro allemand ce qui veut
dire qu'à terme vous pouvez pas
emprunter avec des taux extrêmement
différent entre l'italie et l'allemagne
donc ça veut dire que releva banque
centrale c'est finalement dû gérer les
spread alors que après le revenu dessus
c'est à dire les écarts d'emprunt en
tant que l'allemagne était le mieux à
savoir des conséquences fortes donc
l'europe va avoir un rôle à jouer sur la
question des règles budgétaires ou
l'avait dit un effectivement qu'est ce
que sont les dépenses d'investissement
qu'on peut sortir de là et puis après
sur le phénomène de relocalisation c est
ce qu'on va mettre une taxe carbone aux
frontières qui a un vrai un vrai sujet
on voit que justement avoir une
indépendance
justement de production sur ses chaînes
de production qui sont de plus en plus à
risque aujourd'hui pose un problème un
problème écologique
et puis à terme oui la question de la
relocalisation c'est quand même quelque
chose à dire quoi
et derrière moi indépendant et la
gestion de la stratégie des actifs
stratégiques transfert de l'indus est ce
que made in france
voilà amédée et produire est-ce que
produire des respirateurs est ce que
c'est un actif stratégique sur
l'industrie est ce que produire des
masques c'est un actif stratégique
pire il faut repenser tout ça est pas
penser qu'en fait on peut être juste sur
des chaînes de production éclatée avec
une compétitivité coûts qu'ils soient
toujours toujours de plus en plus dures
souverainisme souveraineté française
terreau sectionnistes dans c'est pas
pareil souveraineté protectionnisme
c'est ça aussi c'est cette question là
ce procès se protéger oui effectivement
mais bon là on débourse ortyl du corde
mais non mr donner des exemples très
concrets de ce qui pourrait justement
permettre un changement de braquet et
qui est absolument indispensable c'est
pas moi j'ai pas plus d'europe pour plus
d'europe je veux plus ordre parce que
c'est plus efficace d'avoir des réponses
à 27 c'est plus efficace quand on est
libre on doit faire face à un certain
nombre de crises majeures de pouvoir
répondre ensemble et c'est uniquement
pour cette raison là mais tout doit pas
se résumer non plus à la question
européenne je l'entends quand on va
mettre des systèmes de protection en
place sur le plan social pour les
chômeurs comme emmanuel macron viens de
le dire prendre 100% du chômage partiel
en charge par l'état c'est quand même
une mesure très concrète ça c'est pas
qu'un discours je crois que là ils
mettent les actes immédiatement en
oeuvre
eh bien eh bien on va devoir poursuivre
cela dans un certain nombre d'autres
domaines
c'était mesures de soutien quand il
parle d'un autre modèle de développement
d'un deux mesures de rupture il ya
effectivement deux choses il ya comment
on a sur le plan politique les moyens
d'agir face à un certain nombre de
crises majeures et pour ça il faut
remettre un certain nombre de règles
budgétaires européennes en cause
on en a parlé et puis il ya aussi
effectivement qu'est ce qui relève du
service public du commun et qu'est ce
qui relève du marché et par exemple là
on voit que nos aînés sont par exemple
exposé de manière importante à ce risque
sanitaire
il faudra effectivement aller demain
vers un service public qui puissent les
protéger alors un service public qui
prend en charge des personnes
dépendantes qui protège nos aînés à
paris agnès buzyn le propose d'ailleurs
un service public de maintien à domicile
pour pour pour les aînés c'est tout un
tas de questions comme ça qui va se
poser est effectivement qu est-ce qu on
sort un peu du du pur marché pour entrer
dans le giron du service public ça c'est
effectivement des choix qu'il faudra
faire en france alors village de la
providence service public on va écouter
jamais été contre l'état providence le
ministre s'est dit je ne sais pas de
leur métro ont été secourus par affrété
ce que vous venez de dire on va écouter
ministre de l'économie et des finances
bruno le maire qui parle même lui d'un
nouveau modèle capitaliste écouter
l'avoir dit d'ailleurs même avant cette
crise économique
il y aura un avant et un après la crise
du coronavirus sur l'organisation des
échanges la mondialisation cela fait
plusieurs mois que je vous dis qu'il
faut inventer un nouveau capitalisme
polonais je vous dise ils sont tous
devenus alter capitaliste l'interminable
non merci on se réjouit encore une fois
on se réjouit ils ont enfin compris
faire que en effet quand on parle
concrètement de ce que ça signifie de ne
pas dépendre d'eux d'autres pays pour
des actifs stratégiques pour des points
qui sont absolument essentielles ça
nécessite ensuite des mesures concrètes
comment on fait pour relocaliser une
partie de l'économie
ça va prendre du temps il faut décider
en effet comme vous le disiez quels sont
les éléments qu'on va produire ici qu'on
doit produire ici le ministre de
l'économie quand on interroge pour
l'instant c'est quand même très très
vague c'est à dire que finalement on
s'aperçoit que oui c'est tout quelques
poncifs sur les nouvelles technologies
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
important qu'on sache le faire
à aucun moment on ne comprend comment
concrètement on va produire ce qu'il
permettra de ne pas être dépendant
d'autres pays
comment on fait pour que l'industrie
pharmaceutique ne produisent pas
totalement car à ses paroles par
agresseurs % manche
je sais comment on fait alors comment
les oblige est-ce qu'on en privateer est
ce qu on a nationalisé une part allongé
jusqu'au bout ou est ce qu'on met des
règles très strictes qui permettent
voilà et quelles règles c'est tout ça
qui va faire être aidé à voir combien de
temps ça peut prendre sorte de
conversion comme ça d'une remettrait en
cause
je trouve ça très bien qu'ils aient
cette orientation en 2008 suite à la
crise nicolas sarkozy avait fait même ce
même revirement très interventionniste
effectivement contre la finance est
complètement dérégulé enfin bon la
question c'est qu'il faut avoir de la
mémoire après et comment on fait c'est
justement la question c'est par exemple
au niveau européen
quels sont les secteurs qu'on pourrait
subventionner par exemple parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est toute subvention
est une distorsion de concurrence
donc ça veut dire remettre en cause même
le modèle même de construction
européenne c'est arthur est ce que la
concurrence à tout va on fonctionne
quand tu voudrais avoir un certain
nombre d'industries qui doivent se
localiser la question c'est que les
autres pays n'ont pas fait
voilà donc clairement il va falloir
redéfinir au niveau national mais au
niveau européen effectivement ce qui
permet vous étudiez forcément les
politiques de l'ensemble des états
l'allemagne
elles suivent déjà on va frère parce
qu'il ya eu déjà des changements sur un
certain nombre de choses et notamment
les décrets qui avait été sur la
question des actifs stratégiques que
vous pourriez protéger en cas justement
d'opéra un certain nombre de boîtes un
qui faisait par exemple en france il ya
vu le décret ensuite à alstom avec
arnaud montebourg
en allemagne ce qui est émis mais là il
va falloir accélérer c'est-à-dire
accéléré et considérer une certaine
liste aussi sur les questions sanitaires
serre que c'est pas juste l'industrie de
pointe c'est aussi sur des choses du
quotidien qui peuvent s'avérer extra
dispensable par exemple si on va dire à
l'ancien la voiture il faut que la
france puisse refabriquer les voitures
de bout en bout de chaîne totalement
dans son versant pas forcément ayant
même parce que pourquoi pas sur
certaines choses c'est à dire qu'il ya
aussi une dimension d'indépendance par
le fait qu' on n'a pas un chômage de
masse qui nous exposent à la moindre
crise terre que produire en france ça
permet aussi de ne pas avoir des gens
qui sont dans une situation totalement
précaires quand surgit une crise comme
celle là c'est pour ça que juste je vous
vois opiné du chef rien tâche et quand
on parle de du fait que de repenser à
l'échelle européenne oui mais encore une
fois le modèle d'europe que vous avez
défendu depuis que vous êtes en
politique le modèle défendu par emmanuel
ma course n'était pas celui là et vous
avez expliqué à tous les gens qui
critiquaient le modèle actuel d'union
européenne qu'ils étaient anti européen
star allons essayer de vous dire mais ça
ne marche pas c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire et ce que vous êtes allé
encore capable de convaincre
j'ai simplement autour de 10 mois
changer petit à ce point qu' il ne
fallait pas parce que l'europe avait
n'avait pas toutes les vertus dont on
aimerait la part immédiatement revenir
sur l'idée de projet européen défend bec
et ongles depuis le début de mon
engagement politique le revenu
vous pouvez pas dire ça dans le paysage
politique français il ya quand même
aujourd'hui des forces extrêmement
importantes qui vont d'ailleurs d'un
motoriste de l'échiquier politique que
ce soit marine le pen d'à côté où jean
luc mélenchon de l'autre qui vous
explique très clairement que j'ai pas
entendu jean luc mélenchon et cyril
venez quasiment sur le site en tout cas
on assure une tel niveau d'exigence de
mélenchon du temps que l'europe ne fera
pas aussi bien que la france en matière
sociale on frappe à l'europe bon bah
voilà d'accord alors moi je pense je
pose le principe de l'europe politique
et de la démocratie européenne pour vous
la mondialisation après j'ai toujours
dit que malheureusement oui pour l'homme
de gauche que je suis forcé de constater
que l'europe a toujours été plutôt de
droite mais ça après je suis donc je me
bats pour que ça change voilà mais je ne
serai pas je ne laisserai pas remettre
en cause l'idée européenne parce qu'
elle ne fonctionne pas exactement comme
j'aimerais à un moment une occasion de
l'argenté vous avez reconnu vous même
que président de la république essayé
depuis des mois d'emmener un certain
nombre de pays dans cette direction
aujourd'hui il ya une crise majeure qui
peut provoquer une prise de conscience
moi je souhaite pour enfin on puisse y
arriver parce qu'on aura cette prise de
conscience à peu plus généralisée ma
question est simple si sap avançait tu
l'attends le faire cette décision de
rupture et convaincre les allemands et
par le passé des histoires a montré que
c'était très difficile si ça n'était pas
possible à l'échelle européenne ce qu'il
faut faire en france
voilà ce programme de nouveaux modèles
uniquement en francs mais de toute façon
il ya un certain nombre de sujets sur
lesquels il faudra jouer au niveau
national on le disait juste avant pour
la protection sociale pour un certain
nombre de services publics c'est
évidemment en france qu'il va falloir
fermer pour ses grandes pour ces grands
sujets de d'économies qui finalement
dépasse le seul cadre national ou pour
faire face à des menaces qui sont elles
aussi international là il va falloir
trouver des partenaires emmanuel macron
quand il essaye quand il a fallu trouver
des partenaires sur un certain nombre de
sujets je pense par exemple à l'accueil
des réfugiés et que l'union européenne
allait n'allait pas assez vite
il a su faire il a su trouver des pays
qui voulaient avancer avec lui s'il faut
un moment en passer par là aussi pour
entraîner finalement un noyau dur qui en
europe ou en tout cas qui se dopaient
donnant un certain nombre de pays qui
seraient prêts à coopérer ensemble pour
faire face un certain nombre de défis
pourquoi pas moi mon mantra il est
simple il est de dire qu'effectivement
vous avez un certain nombre de
problématiques de problématiques par ben
oui qui sont transnationales et donc il
faut pouvoir y répondre sur le plan
transnationales sans dogme par rapport à
ça rappelle que vous représentez plus
la gauche de la république en marche
vous avez discuté avec vos collègues
depuis ce discours et notamment de la
fin de ce discours comment il est perçu
on a évidemment le sentiment que la
campagne présidentielle est lancée est
ce que ce tournant là il est attendu par
par la majorité
vous allez évidemment beaucoup de gens
qui sont se réjouissent effectivement
qu'on puisse remettre la question des
protections la question finalement de
d'une plus grande solidarité au coeur de
la suite du quinquennat alors on peut
toujours dire pourquoi ça n'est pas
arrivé plus tôt moi j'essaie de voir le
verre à moitié plein vous avez
aujourd'hui des actes forts près par le
président de la république vous avez un
chemin qui est tracée maintenant à nous
de nous en emparer de faire des
propositions et je vous assure qu'on
sera au rendez vous pour écouter à
nouveau
bruno le maire et je vous interromps
juste après mathieu plane il parlait de
la politique de l'offre qui au fond
continuera mais qui n'est pas
incompatible avec avec un état fort un
état protecteur écouter politique de
l'offre n'a jamais voulu dire et j'ai
toujours été très clairs là dessus que
l'état abandonné son rôle de protection
et aujourd'hui il a un rôle pour
protéger pour défendre nos entreprises
pour soutenir l'économie
et il va le jouer à plein mathieu plane
on peut faire une politique de l'offre
de soutien aux entreprises qui baisse
les charges qui essaye de jouer sur le
coût de travail et en même temps
défendre un état protecteur dans
certains secteurs stratégiques
il y a oui on peut on va dire le
problème c'est revers est question
européenne c'est que aujourd'hui on est
allé loin dans ses politiques de forme
de dévaluation fiscale de compétitivité
c'est à dire on au ps on essaie de
baisser les cotisations le coût du
travail la fiscalité du capital
comment c'est compatible avec justement
plus protégé plus de service public il
ya quand même une question qui va se
poser qui s'est mal posée pour le haut
niveau européen on le voit sur par
exemple ou si la taxe gafa on n'a pas
été capable au niveau européen de mettre
en place une taxe aujourd'hui la
concurrence fiscale sur le capital n'a
jamais été aussi dur au niveau européen
donc moi je veux bien je suis pour plus
protégés pour avoir un certain nombre de
secteurs qu'ils soient plus stratégique
et qu'on mette les moyens dessus mais
avant ça veut dire remettre en question
aussi cette course à la concurrence
fiscale
aujourd'hui l'europe ne n'importe pas
des réponses
ce qui veut pas dire que
individuellement on peut pas se faire
des mesures de compétitivité d'un côté
et répondre à des mesures d'urgence
c'est pas c'est pas incompatible c'est à
long terme
en fait cette vision globale et
cohérente si on veut vraiment avoir une
stratégie on va parler pour terminer
d'une autre victime de cette crise j'ai
nommé la culture les musées les théâtres
les opéras toutes les salles de
spectacles vont fermer jusqu'à nouvel
ordre c'est le premier ministre qui a
annoncé l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 100 personnes
suivent en quelque sorte le conseil de
matteo renzi il ya quelques jours qui
nous lançait cet avertissement écoutez
brise s'il vous plaît ne sous-évalué pas
le risque comme nous l'avons fait parce
que de nombreuses personnes décident
comme en france la semaine dernière au
royaume uni ou encore en allemagne to go
d'aller au théâtre au musée ce qu'ils
veulent dire
n'ayez pas peur nous allons au théâtre
c'est une bonne réaction quand il y à
une attaque terroriste
nous montrons notre résilience mais
quand il y a un virus
nous devons éviter de rester dans les
lieux publics natacha polony les salles
de spectacle pratiquement tout puisque
c'est 100 100 personnes maximum vont
devoir en tout cas fermé temporairement
ça c'est un coup de massue eux aussi non
mais c'est un coup de massue pour tout
le monde de la culture est de toute
façon quelle qu'elles étaient fermés ou
pas les gens ne s'y rendent pas dire que
là il faut s'attendre à une casse
absolument dramatique dans tous les
domaines de la culture de l'événementiel
et là il va falloir que l'état soit au
rendez vous pour aider pour faciliter
pour compenser parce qu'il ya des gens
qui vont rester sur le carreau dans tous
ces métiers là les toutes les maisons
d'édition sont en train de reporter les
sorties de livres fabre en est face à
une crise qui va avoir des conséquences
dramatiques sur la vie concrète des gens
donc
on parlait de choses qui se peuvent
sembler plus abstraites aux citoyens
mais en fait ces éléments qui semblent
plus abstrait c'est la question de la
capacité pour qu'ensuite l'état puisse
agir très concrètement face à ce qui va
être oui tragique pour beaucoup de gens
on a juste un mot c'est que en fait il
faut savoir que cette cette crise elle
touche pas l'ensemble des secteurs de la
même façon et c'est vrai que les
secteurs liées au tourisme ou à
l'événementiel en général ou loisirs ou
secteurs artistiques sont extrêmement
impacté et on le voit c'est ils sont
vraiment en première ligne et ils vont
passer d'un chiffre d'affaires quasiment
enfin voilà une baisse d'activité énorme
ce qui peut être de 70 80 % le problème
c'est que ces secteurs ont aussi
beaucoup d'emplois sous forme de ce
qu'on appelait les contrats temporaires
typiquement cdd et intérim et ça le
chômage partiel ne permet pas de
protéger donc hier une grande question
sur l'emploi c'est que justement les
ajustements ont passé beaucoup par
l'intérim et notamment les cdd
or on va tomber pile au moment où la
réforme de l'assurance chômage est mis
en place et qui va limiter ses droits
donc moi j'ai une question qui va se
poser c'est que si on veut limiter aussi
la casse ou d'un point de vue social et
notamment dans ces secteurs là va se
poser la question de l'élargissement des
droits au moins d'une façon temporaire
pour y attacher les propos cette
question là oui on reporte voir on
annule sa presse et l'avenir de la cfdt
et de laurent berger moi je pense
qu'effectivement dans une période comme
celle ci les droits rechargeables au
chômage qui avaient été qui retient qui
sont mis en suspension par par cette
réforme en tout cas réduit puisque ont
finalement la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
finalement c'était revenir au système
tel qu'il était avant la crise de 2008
bon et à une crise qui arrive donc il va
falloir revenir certainement au système
prévu pendant les crises il faudra aller
plus loin on avait on avait proposé une
loi en 2018 vous savez pour étendre le
chômage aux travailleurs indépendants
cela n'a été fait que de manière très
partielle
moi je serais pour que justement on
invente de nouvelles protections pour ce
type de travailleurs parce que je ne
crois pas que travail indépendant soit
condamnée en soi en revanche il faut une
protection sociale qui soit adapté et
donc là on a besoin effectivement
peut-être de mettre cette réforme en
suspens comme le demandeur en verger et
puis de reprendre cette question des
protections pour un servant de
travailleurs qui sont aujourd'hui prêts
car c'est quand même dommage puisque ça
cette crise
nous permet de nous apercevoir qu en
effet les réformes qui vont été faite
par la république en marche sont celles
qui retirait des droits alors que
l'ajout de droits aux travailleurs
indépendants qui était une promesse de
campagne ça n'a pas été fait a été fait
mais de manière trop timide a été le
rapporteur de la loi et effectivement je
le dis je je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui aller beaucoup plus loin
j'avais souhaité qu'à l'époque on y
intègre un certain nombre de
travailleurs qui sont dits
auto-entrepreneurs et c'est la manière
dont était construite la réforme
aujourd'hui c'est grand c'est difficile
pour eux parce qu'il faut pas rentrer
dans les détails mais il faut liquider
faire une liquidation judiciaire de son
entreprise que ne font pas les auto
entrepreneurs c'est trop cher donc
peut-être que il faut pouvoir reprendre
effectivement cette question et aller
beaucoup plus loin en tout cas moi je le
souhaite et c'est à lui l'arrivée de
camille saféris qui vous écoutent
attentivement camille qui va terminer
cette édition avec sa chronique tout à
l'heure et qui est également comédien
oui je suis intermittent du spectacle
moreuil c'est vrai que autour de moi je
vois c'est vraiment une hécatombe quoi
c'est c'est épouvantable c'est la
fermeture de tous les théâtres à paris
tout l'été à deux ferme
il ya des gens qui cherchent des heures
qui cherche à faire des catcheurs zordo
de boulot qui veulent faire du
baby-sitting mais payés au cachet
février c'est bon les mesures de soutien
à la fois aux salariés et aux
entreprises
le chômage partiel le chômage technique
vous allez on va voir c'est déjà très
difficile d'être intermittents depuis
quelques années il ya eu beaucoup de
voilà bon je vais pas mais c'est déjà
très compliqué pour les gens qui font
que du spectacle vivant par exemple
c'est vraiment en plus c'est une annus
horribilis là vraiment il ya eu les
grèves des transports qui ont été très
impactante déjà donc là c'est vraiment
le temps d'aider de la culture là il est
en quarantaine parce qu'il a été par le
virus mais mais vous attendez des
mesures désespère oui j'imagine de façon
un peu plus générale
aurélien taché est ce qu'il faut une
pause dans les réformes est normalement
l'assemblée reprend ses travaux après
les après le deuxième tour donc le 23
mars dans dix jours
c'est la réforme audiovisuelle il ya la
réforme des retraites au sénat
est-ce qu'il faut s'arrêter mais
continue mais dans votre question on
sent déjà que le mou réforme et il est
connoté ça peut aussi être mettre en
place ça peut aussi être maître mettre
en place ce qui ressortira de la
convention citoyenne sur le climat donc
moi je ne crois pas qu'il faille y poser
le stylo je ne crois pas qu'il faille
qu'on arrête de travailler et est
d'essayer de faire ce qu'on pense bon
pour le pays y compris au delà de la
gestion de la crise c'est à dire on
parle de changement de modèle ce soyons
modestes mais enfin en tout cas si on
veut aller vers là il va bien falloir
prendre des des réformes importantes
donc voilà je ne crois pas qu'il faille
que nous nous arrêtions simplement il
faudra peut-être prioriser les réformes
qui sont de nature à compenser des
solidarités les protections l'écouté je
vous ai donné quelques exemples mais par
exemple moi je pense que la dépendance
maintenant c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui va falloir mettre en place et de
manière extrêmement urgente sur la
question de notre système de santé et a
peut être des choses qu'il faudra
prolonger aussi donc c'est plutôt vers
là qu'il va falloir se diriger et
peut-être un peu moins je sais si je
répond parfaitement à votre question sur
celle qui visait à moderniser l'économie
à libéraliser un certain nombre de
choses et c'est cindy qui n'est pas à
remettre en cause en soit moi je ne dis
pas que j'ai soutenu sa réforme et je
suis content de l'avoir fait mais j'ai
toujours pensé que c'était un volet de
la politique qu'on avait mené et qui est
un deuxième volet qu'il faut mettre en
place
il était question de faire de toute
façon dans ce fameux acte 2 aujourd'hui
il va falloir le faire très vite et très
à l'acte est donc en fait tout cas il
est accéléré la situation c'est le 20ème
acte 2 à peu près puisque tous les mois
on a droit à l'acte 2 du quinquennat
donc on espère que cela sera vraiment le
bon cette fois ci pour réellement faire
une politique qui ne soit pas celle qui
a été fait avant cette émission sur les
élections municipales donc qui sont
maintenus c'est une certitude maintenant
avant cela on va regarder notre dernier
volet de la série sur rouen à l'ombre du
nuage
lubrizol c'est signé nathalie gloire et
françois jauffret
[Musique]
où
proulx c'est une ville divisée entre
deux rives avec comme séparation la
scène ce journaliste connaît bien la
ville et pour lui cette division et
physique mais aussi sociologique donc en
dérive droite ici avec la scène qui va
vraiment être une frontière naturelle
qui structureront avec sa rive gauche
qui est beaucoup plus industrielles
beaucoup plus populaires aussi alors que
la rive droite centre-ville et tune un
quartier plusieurs quartiers qui sont
plus bourgeois et qui sont plus
historique
mais pour ce journaliste lincendie de
lubrizol n'impactera pas majoritairement
l'oeuvre des rohan et ce n'est pas une
question qui est déterminante pour le
choix du vote les écologistes avaient
déjà ce temps d'avant ce qu'on leur
accorde dans les sondages et qu'on
pressent avant la catastrophe lubrizol
mais évidemment ça ça crée une
atmosphère que ça soit déterminant non
mais ça crée une atmosphère où tous les
partis sont en tout cas obligé d'en
parler est obligé de s'aligner d'avoir
une position là-dessus tout ça oui pas
d'impact sur le vote donc selon ce
journaliste mais la catastrophe de
lubrizol a plutôt renforcé une défiance
voire une colère vis-à-vis des aigus de
nombreuses manifestations ont lieu juste
après l' incendie
ce député qui a lubrizol dans sa
circonscription a bien ressenti ce
sentiment de colère il ya une peur
légitime de la population avec on a
senti pendant plusieurs semaines et une
inquiétude très forte un sentiment
d'abandon si c'est essentiel que la
parole publique soit refaite avec
transparence avec une diffusion
d'informations au maximum pour que les
citoyens puissent se rendre compte que
effectivement il ya rien qui n'est caché
même si le traumatisme est toujours là
le quotidien des rouennais a repris le
dessus aujourd'hui
reste à savoir si leur colère se
ressentira ce dimanche dans les urnes
c'était indispensable de le maintenir
franchement ce ces élections municipales
côté c'était un disque on vient la
question de la cohérence des mesures
près on a à priori un dispositif qui
permettra vraiment aux gens de ne pas
être mis en danger
la question s'est posée les
scientifiques ont répondu que ce n'était
pas nécessaire forcément de mettre un
report de la session ont aussi demandé
très fort à ce que ces élections soient
maintenues donc que le fait même d'avoir
envisagé de les reporter n'est pas
rassurant c'était normal de se poser la
question dans le moment où en est il
faut il faut tout mettre sur la table
déjà le premier tour qui est maintenu on
verra ce qu a dit président de la
république pour l'instant on maintient
le premier tour et on verra ce qui se
passe la semaine prochaine pour le
moment on peut encore y avoir il ya des
choses si j'ai bien noté ce qu'il a dit
c'était pour l'instant maintien des
élections fin du premier tour dimanche
j'ai bien retenu premier tour oui donc
premier point pour le coup on peut
considérer que c'est en effet
l'opposition des républicains qui a
véritablement effet savoir que ce serait
un scandale de reporter ces élections
donc là on ne peut pas non plus
considéré que ce serait de la faute du
président de la république ne sachant
qu' on peut pas non plus le soupçonner
de m
la population française en danger
volontairement c'est pas le sud s'est
pas à mettre sur le même plan que les
écoles les écoles on sait très bien
enfin quiconque a des enfants c'est que
le contact la façon dont peuvent
circuler des virus dans les écoles c'est
pas exactement la même chose que d'aller
dans un bureau de vote de façon prudente
c'est tout à fait juste mais c'est vrai
quand on regarde maintenant les courbes
les courbes de progression de cette
épidémie notamment en italie et en
allemagne elles sont exponentielles et
ils sont exactement superposables à ce
qui arrive dans notre pays et quand on
regarde ce qu'ils font est ce qu'on fait
on peut se dire alors est-ce qu'on n'est
pas en deçà ça la question
je pense qu'il ya un équilibre qui est
très complexe à trouver entre le ce qui
va éviter la panique et ce qui éviterait
trop de laxisme
c'est un équilibre subtil on peut
considérer que telle mesure ne va pas
dans mon sang je il apparaît très
clairement que le président de la
république a cherché à atteindre cet
équilibre c'est à dire à ne pas sombrer
dans une panique totale est dans
l'irrationnel
ce qui me frappe depuis le début de
cette crise c'est le l'absence totale de
rationalité qui se répand dans des pays
qui sont censés des pays où les gens
sont éduqués ont un minimum de
connaissances scientifiques
évidemment qu'on n'a pas les
connaissances total sur ce virus on voit
bien que les scientifiques eux mêmes ont
des discours contradictoires mais face à
cela
ça sert à rien non plus de se précipiter
dans les supermarchés pour acheter de
l'eau en bouteille il ya un moment où il
faut aussi que nous tous et en
particulier les médias nous essayons de
garder un discours à peu près
raisonnable c'est-à-dire de dire ce
qu'on peut savoir ce qu'on ne peut pas
savoir ce qu'on peut envisager et quels
sont les actes nécessaires pour se
protéger avant que vous passez la parole
pour votre chronique qui a préparé j'ai
mon masque dans la poche
vous ne craignez pas une abstention
massive et peut-être même des recours a
posteriori perdre un candidat
d'abstention forcément certains
notamment les personnes âgées vont
peut-être hésitez encore une fois tout
est mis en oeuvre pour que y ait aucune
difficulté voilà je gens nous verrons
bien tout ce qui est certain c'est que
on ne peut pas nous avoir dit qu'on
allait perdre ces élections municipales
et puis aujourd'hui nous reprocher de
les maintenir pour de mauvaises raisons
on le fait parce qu'on était sous
contrôle ne soit pas là prévient après
je pense que c'est ce que natacha polony
avis est très vrai c'est à dire qu'il
faut trouver l'équilibré entre comment
on ne met pas non plus une espèce de
psychose généralisée dans le pays on
voit bien qu'on en ait déjà pas très
loin donc c'est sûr que si on met tout
tout tout tout tout en suspens on risque
d'aggraver aussi ce ressenti de la part
des français s'est dit allez on passe à
kamerhe camille est là chaque vendredi
normalement entouré d'autres
chroniqueurs mais qui pour des raisons
diverses n'ont pas pu venir aujourd'hui
les ombres vous avez aurélien tâche et
camille fait chaque semaine au fond
découvrir à nos téléspectateurs des
députés de façon un peu différente
vous allez voir oui c'est à dire que je
vais boire un verre en fait avec avec un
député à chaque fois différent alors
cette semaine j'ai bu un verre avec
pierre dharréville qui est député pcf de
denis martin du gard
on s'est retrouvés au café français à la
bastille très chic et très sympathique
loyers très symbolique
alors pierre dharréville il et il est
très sympa d'abord c'est un ancien
journaliste est un poète et c'est le
député qui a une boucle d'oreille
il a une grosse boucle d'oreille à
l'oreille gauche comme corto maltese
comme bernard lavilliers voyez c'est un
poète alors il a fait partie d'un groupe
qui s'appelle figurez-vous les bombarde
jeux de mots il est donc il est chanteur
guitariste compositeur et l'or comme je
connaissais pas moi sur doute les
bombarde
eh ben je lui ai demandé quelle était
donc les tubes du groupe ofer de
figuerolles tapis dans les broussailles
mais voyait là vous me faites chanter
dans un bar de fer les rôles puis dans
les brosses et un fort qu'ils se
trouvent
sur la côte bleue dans la rade de
marseille voulait pas me dire des titres
du futur album dans des titres la
couleur de ton ciel c'est pas mal sa
douleur de ton ciel j'aime la couleur de
ton ciel voilà un rocker ouais voyez
alors quand il était petit donc pierre
dharréville figurez vous qu'il est venu
visiter l'assemblée nationale avec sa
classe et il s'en rappellent très très
bien on rappelle une fois est revenue à
l'assemblée nationale quand j'étais au
collège alors c'était comment vous visez
d'impressionnant mais ce qui
impressionne d'abord c'est quoi le
velours rouge les clous côté capitane et
non c'est pas ça c'est un lieu
d'histoire lieu où
visuel et grandeur de notre pays ont
résonné mais vous vous êtes pas dit un
jour j'y serai non mais je me rappelle
très bien que le prof
vous avez dit dans votre classe y en
aura au moins un qui sera député mais je
pense qu'il doit le dire à toutes ces
classements voilà voilà peut-être pas si
si si je vous rassure un gars que de
loin sur le sur le barça oui bien sûr
c'est la loi toute façon c'est la loi
alors pierre dharréville depuis toujours
et des fans de bd
il a même été chroniqueur il parlait de
parler de bd dans le temps dans
plusieurs journaux
et puis utilise est donc évidemment
fripounets triolo les héros de sa
génération et il a repris la rédaction à
un moment de piles gadget qui a été
relancée en quelques temps oui dans les
années 2000
alors il y avait le retour de placid et
muzo hercules
il y avait des bd d'hugo pratt a quand
même été abrogée oui je l'aï joué à
wigan était communiste moi donc j'ai un
gadget
quand j'étais petit et puis il y avait
rarement le fils de crao vous souvenez
le le le créateur de rares ont
d'ailleurs viens viens de vient de
mourir je crois la semaine dernière donc
sur des lots il y avait effectivement
une influence politique peut-être dans
dans les bandes dessinées depuis il ya
jack parce que on savait que c'était un
journal lié au parti communiste
même si les enfants se rendaient pas
forcément compte alors on en a parlé
avec pierre darré vide par exemple les
aventures de rang
de l'époque il y avait toujours quand
même cette manière de mettre en avant
l'ouverture d'esprit de ce qui pend beau
le slip en peau ouais il y avait ça
aussi il y avait de tout dans pif y
avait des dégâts qu'il y avait des
rigoles us et les tristes us y arrive
dans mon souvenir il y avait deux
peuples y avait les tristes et les les
joyeux quoi et vous vous êtes plutôt
rigoler ce tristesse ouais je passais au
gendre un juge et moi j'aime bien
rigoler de l' influence de pif gadget et
de la bd en général sur sur la pensée du
jour je suis passé c'est difficile de
faire des liens comme ça mais bon voilà
après j'ai pas oublier ça s'est bien
passé oui c'est une part d'enfance une
part de tout ça on a chacun en nous faut
pas l'oublier
bon et puis d'arriver vraiment à sortir
à chaque travée mais chose chacun moi je
suis fascinée me disent jamais ce genre
de combat louis veut c'est le principe
c'est c'est pour ça que je vais devoir
évoquer d'autres choses alors bien sûr
évidemment dans pif gadget il y avait
les gadgets 1 vous en souvenez sûrement
il y avait des peas
il y avait les yeux car et les haricots
magiques vous souvenez tout ça bon et
puis il y avait des pois sauteurs dit
alors est ce qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait
peut-être des gadgets pour l'assemblée
je crains vide
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui manquent
aux députés c'est à dire est ce qu'il ya
des choses qu'il faudrait inventer des
gadgets qui vous sera utile auquel on
pense pas forcément un député tu vois le
truc pour tenir comme ça quand on
s'endort en réunion un faux coup comme
ça existe si vous allez à par exemple
vous prenez l'avion vous savez vous
pourrez venir mais ils sortent d'eux
la wii devrait proposer ça richard
ferrand s'il accepterait de donner à
chaque député moi vous prenez rendez
vous avec aurélien tâche et orientale et
prenez rendez vous avec tennis halle
berry dévoilerez un petit peu au
comptoir 24 partie d'un groupe de
musique mais je sens que ça va être un
bon client
merci camille vous recevez bah je
reviens je sache a posé nue d'être venu
sur le plateau de lcp merci aurait bien
attaché il n'y aura pas d'émission la
semaine prochaine pour cause de trêve
électorale merci infiniment à l'équipe
de sa burqa
fabrice quéro sylvain poulet fanny saly
où les eaux et constant très bon week
end à vous profitez bien et a très vite
[Musique]